brasil acaba de superar los 5 millones
de casos de coronavirus y además está
muy cerca de superar las 150 mil muertes
pero los expertos advierten de que la
situación podría ser mucho peor habría
que multiplicar los casos por 6 eso es
cerca de 30 millones de brasileños
podrían haber ya contraído este virus
mientras en las ciudades de brasil vemos
una situación de casi normalidad mucha
gente en las calles el río de janeiro
las playas llenas también los centros
comerciales funcionando como si no
hubiese una pandemia en curso las cifras
oficiales muestran desde hace dos
semanas una bajada los muertos se quedan
por debajo de los 700 diarios sin
embargo hay que recordar que brasil es
un país enorme de 210 millones de
habitantes y los focos se van moviendo
entonces hay mucha disparidad entre una
región y otra por ejemplo sao paulo la
ciudad más afectada
ha tenido una baja pero desde hace unos
días la curva se ha estabilizado el río
de janeiro también que es la segunda
ciudad más afectada del país ha habido
cambio a lo largo de las últimas semanas
hubo una bajada de los casos luego hubo
un repunte de casi dos semanas ahora
parece que de nuevo los casos están
remitiendo manaos la ciudad cuya imagen
dio la vuelta al mundo porque hubo que
cavar fosas comunes es estar planteando
la posibilidad de imponer un lock down
de unas dos semanas frente a un nuevo
repunte del 30 por ciento de los casos
en general la situación es un poco
caótica
y al mismo tiempo analógica podríamos
resumir de esta forma el brasileño hace
su cuarentena como mejor le parece y en
general está cansado de esa situación y
prefiere mirar para otro lado